♪ Garyvee the name ♪
♪ Just put your head down ♪
♪ Do the work and everything will change ♪
♪ Sipping tea ♪
♪ Help the feels ♪
♪ That's just what I want and ♪
♪ Being patient hella tricky
if I'm being honest. ♪
♪ Tea with Garyvee ♪
♪ Preaching positivity ♪
- Good morning. Good morning.
Good morning, everybody.
Super excited today.
What date is it?
July 16th.
It is July 16th.
It has been a year in a lot of ways.
And I hope everybody's super well.
Let's go into the comments.
Tyrone Thomas, good to see you.
Meeka Coleman, thank you for joining.
Good morning, good morning,
good morning, Ariana.
Ariana, what was your last?
Enriquez, good to see you
and thank you for coming.
(indistinct) Will, Cheryl Wittingham,
Irena B. Travis Sayers,
(indistinct) Gomi, in the building.
Meghan Lennon in the building.
Dustin, how are you?
Missed all of you.
- Good (coughs).
Sorry.
- You okay over there?
- Yeah.
- Hold on one second.
Hold on one second.
- Well, welcome to tea with
Garyvee I am your host now.
Gary just walks away sometimes.
So I see, I'll just read
comments now I guess.
I see a lot of LinkedIn.
- That was terrible job, Dust.
Are you serious?
- I'm not mentally prepared.
- You have to always be prepared, bro.
- You're right. You're right.
Someone asked if I had any new cards.
So I got my own Squirtle Squad now.
- You getting serious
about the Pokemon, huh?
- Yeah.
- What are those those PSA nines, tens?
- I got a one nine and one 10
and a 9 yellow cheeks.
- I like what I'm seeing.
I like what I'm seeing.
So everybody, let me finish this bagel.
All right, let's get into this show guys.
- Cool.
- Reezy, what's good, bro?
- Dude, what is up?
How are you man? Long time no see.
- Long time no see, it's good to see you.
How you been?
- Good, man, besides everything
being a little bit weird,
and a, you know, just
playing the adaptation game,
which is actually weirdly
business as usual.
It's the reason I've been able to
be in business for 15
years plus for myself
is because, you know, you don't give up
when crazy stuff like this happens.
- No, because the punchline,
and for everybody who's watching is
if you give up, that's
actually the end of the game.
Like if you turn off
your Nintendo, it's over.
Like if you keep playing Contra
and you can eventually win.
- Yeah, this is just a momentary glitch.
Like a little bit of green
screen on the Nintendo.
Just blow in the
cartridge; you'll be good.
(blows two times)
- Yeah, look, I think it comes down
to a lot of what I've been talking about
for the last three years.
Which is like, hey, this has
been a long run of good stuff.
And that's just not how
the world always works.
So save some money, be smart.
Don't overextend yourself, be thoughtful.
You know, be patient.
You know, create tried and true behaviors.
Be kind, and you know,
I think this year has challenged people
in an incredible way.
And you know, hopefully people
are healthy and persevering.
What can I answer for you?
- Yeah, I got a couple questions
for you if you don't mind.
So the first thing that I
want to talk to you about
is really related to what
we were just talking about,
which is the current market trends.
You know, it's hard out
here for a lot of people,
but some people are actually making
a lot of money right now.
- Always.
- Consumer behavior has changed a lot.
And in my opinion, as
a big follower of you,
that is your super power
is consumer behavior.
You know, you know enough about everything
and you keep both of your ears
super glued to the street.
And you hear, you know,
(whispers) from everybody.
And so I feel like,
you know, you just have
this unique, you're an alien bro.
You have the best insight
on this kind of stuff.
So, right now we are in a
current bull market, you know,
stock market, e-commerce
sales are through the roof.
You know, a lot of people are telling me,
"I can't make any money right now."
And I'm like, "Dude, I
can't really help you
if you can't make money right now,
because it's never been easier."
- Meaning in your world of reselling,
there's some people
specifically that are resellers
that are like, yo, I'm getting destroyed.
And you're like, how is that possible
when this is the greatest
era of buying on Amazon ever.
- Right, and you know,
you're just not adapting.
You know, I've sold mostly
books for my entire career,
but I can tell you,
I'm definitely not
selling books right now.
If you go to Google trends.
- Is book sales down right now?
- I wouldn't say they're down.
I would say they're up.
But a lot of things are up a lot more.
And those things have a
much more profit per unit,
you know, and they're less labor involved
and stuff like that.
You know, obviously,
when the shit hit the fan,
everybody was forced to shop online.
So we have all these people
that didn't previously shop online,
they now shopped online.
And they were like, "Whoa!
This shopping online shit's pretty nice.
You know, I like this."
So now they're shopping online.
The buying volume has
increased significantly.
I'd say five to 10 years
of e-commerce consumer behavior growth
in, you know, the last four months.
So with that being said, you know,
I've been telling everybody
like buckle down, you know.
This is going to be the
craziest Q4 ever in history.
Like record level sales for
Christmas and leading up to,
and I don't even think
it's going to slow down
from now until then.
I almost feel sorry for people
that are just getting started now,
because when it goes
back to normal, you know,
they're gonna to have depression.
- Right, because they're
going to be not as good.
- You're like, no, no,
no, this is the normal.
We were on a peak, you know.
But you know, we got what
over a million Americans
on unemployment getting $600 a week.
Stimulus checks are coming in, you know.
Tens of millions of Americans
are unemployed in general.
And you even hear people, you know,
you post how good your sales are.
And people are like, "Oh,
it's those stimulus checks."
You know, even in the
reselling community, you know,
not so out in the open,
but people are like, "bring on wave two.
Bring on wave three."
Like, you know, we're
making a lot of money.
- Bring on wave two and
three of stimulus checks?
- No of lock down.
- Oh, COVID.
- Yeah, I mean it's dark.
But you know, people are making money.
You know I think people
don't really want people
to get sick or whatever,
but people never made money real easily.
So in your opinion, I think
it's about like 11 days,
10 days out, until they
decide to maybe stop
the $600 a week unemployment checks.
Do you see this trend continuing
through the holiday season and onward?
Or do you see like a
depression era level, you know-
- I don't think it's a depression level,
but I do think that
within a 10 year window,
we need to really pay the piper.
And we're just printing money
and people are getting checks
to take care of themselves
that are out of jobs
and they're going out and
buying CDs, not really good,
just like they're just buying things.
This is a very consumer world.
People don't like saving.
And so the fundamentals are not exciting.
You know, the timing of
when, I have no idea,
but there's definitely
incredible short-term behavior,
which leads to a lot of vulnerabilities.
I'm with you.
I think, you know, I don't
think anyone's going outside
for real until after this year.
So I think Q4,
the shopping behavior is so intense.
They're not going to
go to physical stores,
all that goes online.
So there'll be incredible
opportunity through the end...
If I'm in your business,
I go hammy ham ham to the end of the year.
And I literally take
50% of the money I make
and put it in the bank and
let it sit there as cash.
- Yup. Safety net.
- Absolutely what I would do.
If I made $200,000 in sales,
I would take a hundred,
put it in the bank.
And with that hundred, I
would continue to buy things,
run my business, blah, blah, blah.
That's what I would do.
And there's a million factors.
The election's a huge factor.
You know, there's just, you know,
every day anything could happen.
I mean, there could be a new pandemic.
I mean, you know, so, you know,
I think saving money needs
to be thought through.
But like navigating
through good or bad times
just takes execution and mentality.
Like whether it comes
or goes or disappears
or doesn't disappear,
it's kind of irrelevant.
That is completely out of our control.
I am quick to react to what's happening,
but I can't predict.
I don't predict.
I don't know. I don't see future.
I definitely know that
when the government
disproportionally gives out
cadrillions of dollars, and
then the humans in society,
instead of saving it or
doing smart things with it,
go and buy materialistic things,
and then when we get out of it,
people can't get jobs
and those checks are not gonna be there,
that's a problem.
- Yep.
Makes a lot of sense to me.
So the next question that I got
for you is basically around,
it's a really selfish question, so.
But basically around how
you built up team Garyvee.
I'm looking to do the
same thing for myself.
You know, sometime within
the last year or two,
I realized, you know,
I can't do everything.
I can't even post to
Instagram every single day
if I have to also check all
my DMs and check emails.
It's madness; I'm losing
money, you know, opportunities.
I'm missing opportunities, you know.
So the first hire for me
was a really bad ass, personal
assistant, shout out, Mandy.
Hey, Mandy.
- Hey, Mandy.
- She makes everything happen for me.
I have a full time video editor,
and I have an intern.
And that's pretty much
the entire team right now.
And I'm curious with you,
how was the beginning of team Garyvee?
Who was the first hire?
What are the most important
pieces of the puzzle?
Maybe what mistakes have you made?
- Admin, admin, admin's
the most important piece.
So I'm glad you went down that route.
The next most important piece
is the right hand coordinator
of the content, the Andy Kay.
And then next the most important piece
is the creatives in my
world that was Steve Unwin
back in the ask, Garyvee days.
Zack Moy, who runs the Sasha group,
one of the BMX companies,
creative department now.
So for me, it's designer,
video person, and writer
are the three essential pieces.
Someone who writes copy,
somebody who makes pictures,
and somebody who makes video assets.
A coordinator, so that's
the four person team.
Cause we had the project manager,
the architect, the GM, the
person that's your right hand.
- So, full time, like
photo maker for content.
Full time copywriter.
- Yep, full time video.
- Assistant who makes sure
all the content is coming out,
which probably includes scheduling.
- Five person team.
Five person team.
Assistant, the coordinator,
project manager,
GM, whatever you want to call her or him,
design image, video design,
and then copywriting.
And you hire them as you can afford them.
You know, I didn't hire all five at first.
- What order is the most
important out of them
after the assistant?
- Assistant, I would probably then go-
- And video editor.
- I would go assistant.
I would probably go coordinator
that can also do either
video or creative at first.
So like an organized
video or design maker.
Then I would bring in a
design maker or video person,
depending on where you want to go.
You would then have to
be the generator of ideas
or the coordinator or
the admin would have to.
Then the coordinator,
who also has to really
give the ideas and help.
Then the writer.
And then either the video or design person
depending on which one
you didn't do prior.
- Awesome. That's cool, man.
I appreciate it.
I know you still do a lot of
the creative stuff yourself
and you get your eyes on everything.
- I still write all the copy
and like, you know, ideate with the team,
my meeting right after this
is ideation with the team.
So content man content's
the fucking gateway.
- Awesome.
Real quick, before we take off,
I want to hit you with a little piece.
I don't remember, I don't
know if you remember this,
but when I first started
building my personal brand
and I'm following you,
I'm on everything you do.
I'm watching it.
I was really cynical back then.
This was, you know, almost five years ago.
And I remember, you know,
I was listening to
everything you say, you know.
Fuck automation, be real, you know.
And you had posted something
and I forget the exact
situation on Twitter,
but it was extremely
fast, like inhumanly fast,
you know, re activeness on your part.
- You mean I replied?
- Yeah, like to something
I don't remember.
But I was like, I commented
something along the lines of,
you know, like, "Says the guy
that doesn't use automation."
You know, like calling
you out, using automation.
And I swear to God, 10 seconds later,
you replied with a video that said,
"These two thumbs motherfucker;
these two thumbs."
And then I was like, holy shit.
Like he came at me.
Like people don't do that, you know.
And then I said something
like my bad, you know.
And you just replied the
simplest thing, three words.
And it changed my life really
because I was real cynical.
You just said, "Cynics never win."
Can you explain that for the audience,
what you mean by that?
- First of all, it's an epic story.
And I've done, that's
happened more than once.
I'm trying to remember if
I remember the exact one.
But deciding to look at
the world, first of all,
cynics never win is something
that really sits with me
because there's a lot of
people who are cynical,
who are hurting or are concerned
or coming from a place of fear.
And I have a lot of empathy for it.
But what it means is
you're looking for bad.
You're looking for the wrong,
you're spending energy.
And often time looking for the, I got you.
Or like, Oh, these
people like that person,
let me prove that that
person's not as good as that.
Like there's a underlining,
I don't like the word
jealousy believe it or not.
I don't know why I don't like
that word, but I don't really-
- It means you are competitive.
- Yeah, you know, it's not about that.
It's not about me wanting to be just,
I don't even like to label people jealous.
Cause I think that that's not a nice way
to say something to somebody
who actually is probably
hurting slash admiring someone.
So like it's a, I don't know.
But nonetheless, spending energy,
looking for bad is just a bad use of time.
You know, to me it's like,
it's like all that time
and energy spent creeping,
waiting for the aha,
could all be put towards positive behavior
and doing something for
yourself and bringing value.
It's just literally seeing
the world in a negative light
instead of a positive light.
It comes down to confidence
and kind of being in your own bubble.
For me,
I always lead with love, and belief
and trust is given.
And then if one proves that,
that wasn't a good idea,
then I'm okay with that.
But that doesn't hurt my confidence.
It doesn't upset me.
I don't feel like they let me down.
So many people are guarded.
And I think that that is something
I just think a lot about.
It's exhausting to be around cynics.
People that are looking for the wrong.
And right now, I think
the reason so many people
are anxious and tired
is our entire culture,
our entire country in a lot of
ways is on tilt and cynical.
And just like every day
looking for the wrong.
And that's, daunting.
And I think it's leading to a lot of pain
which makes me unhappy for so many people.
Which is why I observe it. I watch it.
But it's also that why I spend my time
doing actions like this
because I want to bring, you know,
I'm hoping this hour
brings a lot of positivity
and a lot of value to people.
- Oh yeah. You know, you're
always bringing the value, man.
(Gary expresses gratitude)
I think that, man, the
way you replied to me
is exactly what I needed, you know,
to understand that if you,
if you're cynical, you know,
I felt so bad in that
moment when I called you out
and you were like, no, I did it.
That's me for real, you were wrong.
And that's when I realized
I'd rather be naive and wrong,
you know, then cynical
because if I'm writing,
then I assume you did it.
And later I found out you
were using automation.
I don't feel bad, you know?
- Yeah. It's like, that's bad on them.
That's my point.
Which is like, bad will
always lose in the end.
Good will always win in the end.
The end, the end, the end.
And it's like, who are all we?
It's almost takes like, to me,
the reason I don't search out
is I don't have enough ego
to think like, it's my
job to figure it out.
Like the world will take care of you.
You may be winning for little
while with your trickery,
but that shit will always lose in the end.
So I don't even need to
spend my energy on that
because the negative thing
will lose in the end,
Even though it might
look like they're not.
People are like, "Oh yeah,
but did you see his Mercedes?"
I'm like, you don't understand
what's happening in that man's soul.
You don't know how that man goes to sleep
with pills and alcohol.
Don't think he's winning
cause he's got some money.
What the fuck's the matter with you?
- Yep. Awesome.
Love you, Gary.
Thank you for your time, brother.
- Any time.
- Peace.
- All right, let's rappen it up.
Let's speed this up a little bit.
- What's up?
- What's good now. How are you?
♪ Hey, preaching positivity, yay. ♪
- Oh, I like that from you.
- Yo, what's happening.
- You look good, (indistinct).
- How are you; how are you?
- Yeah, introduce yourselves.
- First off, we actually
ran out of teabags.
Fuck being Irish.
It's five o'clock somewhere
so we have a little beer.
- I love it. I love it.
Bring it down a little bit there.
I love it. I love it.
- There you go, cheers.
Cheers.
- So, little backstory.
This is Niall, my brother. I'm Killian.
32 year old, 26 year old.
It's all around the word,
but I just wanted to go
back a little bit further.
I didn't have the best start to life.
I was born with like a
pretty rare heart condition
called tragus arteriosus.
I undergone my first operation
whenever I was four weeks old.
Came through it by all
the doctors disbelief
and (audio fades) again.
And then they said I would
probably need another operation.
I was 16, and I'm now 32, as I said.
And I haven't needed
one since, thankfully.
So I was kind of inspired me,
just watching your stuff as well.
It really pushed me to
travel around the world
and just, you always preach
one life, one opportunity,
just get out there and do shit.
And that's what I've been doing,
trying to pursue our career dream
to make it in the music
industry with my brother Niall.
- Pretty much say videographer,
singer, songwriter.
So like kind of-
- We've got like a Billie
Eilish and The Finneas
kind of like a little synergy.
- I love that. I love that.
- So pretty much that, just
a bit of context about me.
I'm Niall, 26 years old.
Started singing like 10 years ago.
Actually funny story,
I was like on the Xbox, you know,
and the little like headset,
like singing with my friends
online, like Xbox 360.
And they had like at a school competition.
Won it, and it kind of
snowballed from there.
And then got the opportunity
to travel for a few years.
Then, so pretty much I stayed afloat,
like hustled in Boston stuff.
You know, just to keep my living.
I made after that came home.
Did the X Factor UK back in 2016,
which is pretty amazing.
Went pretty far in that.
So from that I've like
been building connections
and like, you know, hustling from there.
And I moved to Toronto two years ago
cause my brothers moved here
four years ago, I think.
- Yeah, four years ago
there's two older brothers.
So there's four of us.
So shut out to mom and dad (audio fades).
- The only thing I'm thinking right now is
I'm trying to really listen.
Cause the only thing that
just went through my brain
was like, I need to hang out
with these four fucking brothers.
- Yeah.
- Keep it going. Keep going.
- So pretty much since
I've been in Toronto,
I started, I mean like I've
been singing for 10 years,
but I didn't really take it
seriously as like a career
until about four years ago
since X-Factor kind of inspired me
and made me realize that
I can really, you know,
make this a career.
And obviously Killian is a
video log for content creator.
So it goes really hand-in-hand.
So right now I've been really
focusing on like, you know,
honing in on my original
music and making sure
that I come across as authentic
as like an artist should.
But my first question was
it's weird since I never
thought I'd be this person.
But like, since quarantine
I've been feeling
my own like mental health issues,
like a lot of weird anxiety.
But like a lot of things like-
- Feel like you're running
out of time in your moment.
- Yeah. That was one of the points.
So pretty much-
- (audio fades) No, I really like it,
notice how I zoned in right on that.
It's super cliche. Makes sense, right?
Like you made this move,
you've got this momentum going, fuck.
As soon as I fucking finally
figured out what I want to do
and I've got some momentum going,
fucking COVID, like, you know.
People go to that place.
The reality is it's just not true.
What could happen is
you'll never have a time
where you have this much downtime
with you and your brother just right here.
Instead of being like,
fuck this fucked me up.
You need to go on the offense,
see the positives.
In fact the last thing, it's
either cynicism or optimism.
Like you and your bro are like
fucking chilling together.
And like just fucking
make, he makes videos.
You sing just fucking make content.
- I've been going through phases.
I'm like real, like let's
go hard for a month.
And then all of a sudden
it's also, you know,
yourself working with your
brother and your dad growing up.
It gets a bit like clash of heads.
And we both want the same dream
and the goal at the end of the tunnel.
But sometimes you just
clash heads and like,
and we're very stubborn.
And that's kinda like an Irish
mentality to be stubborn.
And so obviously we're both
fighting for the same thing.
Is there any like advice
you could give us.
- This is where I use darkness for light.
You know, every time I'm struggling,
and I've said this for
anybody who follows me,
I go into a very dark place
of like, and you know,
yeah, we just lost all that business
or this bad thing happened.
But somebody could call me right now
and say, my mom died, right.
So like, not from my standpoint,
like anytime you're
pissed at your brother,
if he was my brother, it'd be so easy.
I'd be like, damn, he
shouldn't even be alive.
His heart's fucked up.
Like honestly I would like
literally go there every time.
And I think it diffuses the, you know,
like you guys are fighting
about should we make a video
or how should a fucking video be made?
And I'd be like, damn, I'm
just happy my brother's alive.
I mean it, I'd really go to that place.
Me and my dad had a
lot of friction, a lot.
You know, me and my dad,
the world totally different.
You know, I came in hot and
every time it got real bad,
like I would cry when we
would fight in my twenties,
you know, but I would go back to my office
and be like, you know, cool.
But like, thank God he's alive.
He lost his dad at 15.
You know what I mean?
Like it's perspective.
Like it's just momentum
of how you see the world.
I see the world, like,
you're lucky as fuck
that you're alive during an
internet era during COVID
because if your parents
lived through COVID,
there was no internet.
There was no connection.
There was no this.
It's is a fucking miracle out here.
- Yeah, that's true.
- So like a follow up question to that was
because of like, feeling
like a bit anxious
and you know, things like that.
My motivation comes in waves.
So like for a month I'm on it real good.
And then like two weeks
off, then two weeks on.
- Good, good. Sounds great.
Better than zero motivation.
Bro, people judge
themselves, nobody goes 365.
Dude, I'm buying sports cards
and spending time on eBay
all day long the last month
because I needed clearly subconsciously,
I needed the release.
- I'm not beating up myself
that I'm not prepping for huge meetings
where millions of dollars are on the line,
because I'm looking up Dr.
Jay rookies at midnight.
Don't judge yourself.
And by the way, do you write?
Do you write? Now, do you write?
- Yeah, of course.
Yeah, I've been writing for
the last like two, three years.
(bad audio) a bit more
like authentic at writing
is like I'm 26 at like 23 IQ mode.
So like that was a huge
burden off my shoulders.
So from that, I think I kind
of released something in me
where I could write more authentically.
- You were hiding,
you were hiding before.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Yeah, which is amazing. Congratulations.
So like my big thing is
take this time together,
and when you get into
the zone of going dark
or not motivated, see if you can make,
I mean you may find out that
that's when you write
your most authentic shit.
- Oh 100%, like it's
the (voice trails off).
- Honestly, I think
you're judging yourself.
I would argue that the number one thing
that fucks up the 10,000 people
that are watching this
right now, every single day
is their disproportionate
judgment of their own selves.
- Yeah.
- You're just living out here, bro.
You're just trying like me, like your bro,
like every fucking person.
Like (indistinct), you
know, like in the comments,
like captabefroman, like stop judging.
Like everyone's just beating
themselves up for no reason.
Like I listen, if you can't
be your number one fan
who the fuck's going to be it.
And I think it comes with humility
and also understanding like
comparison destroys people.
Like I don't give a
fuck about Billie Eilish
and her fucking brother.
Like great motivation.
They're fucking amazing.
But don't, fuck that.
Like don't compare and love yourself.
Don't compare it and love yourself.
Don't compare and love yourself.
You fucking drill that
into your fucking dome
and your whole life, got
a little lightheaded,
(audio becomes unclear)
- I think you're right.
Like that's every little problem
that like small things that build up
and make you feel a certain way
like self esteem and self moment, like-
- That's what you were saying.
Every time I get into like
a, disappointed with myself,
which is the worst, right.
I'm just like, like at right before I go
and like, it's almost like
right before I cross over
into a place I've really not been,
which is like real negative space,
I'm just like
you know what, everybody else sucks too.
(brothers laugh)
I mean it.
- To kinda turn it back onto
like a lighter note as well.
It's obviously not always dark here.
Like we always-
- I'm sure. I'm sure
- We obviously-
- You're Irish boys and
you're in your youth.
You guys are having 50% fun?
You're 50% fun by default,
(laughter)
but, but the key here
and why this is probably
resonating for a lot of people
is if you're 88% fun,
but 12% actual anxiety
and depression and awkwardness and dark
that 12% is heavier than the 88.
- Yeah, of course, like-
- And to me, so go ahead.
- I was just gonna say like
six out of seven days
a week, I'm like fine.
And just as I kinda like
pay bills and stuff,
I'm still trying to find
ways to like make money
off like social media and music and stuff.
I want to have one
single out at the minute,
but I've got a lot of like back
burner like loads of songs.
- Yeah we're making like over
the last couple of years,
like a lot of trips back and
forth between New York and LA
and making connections like
some great connections.
Like Black Eyed Peas manager,
we were in the shitty with him
showing his work off so like we're...
I like to think of myself
as a very good like
connector between people.
I'm good at hustling.
That's where I managed to
get the intro for you guys.
- The cocking attention.
- Yeah, pretty much.
I hit up Dustin's DMs, befriended them
and obviously provided value
and then made the video.
- Dustin, did this man
did this man charm you?
- Yeah, I mean they just made good stuff.
(Niall hits high note)
- Get out of here!
No, come on. Come back.
So we're just, just building
connections and that,
just seeing them just
taking one day at a time
to see how things go.
And then obviously with your help.
And obviously I know you
have a lot of tie ins
with your music right hand man, Mike Boyd.
That's something I'd love to
maybe some further down the line.
So my committee-
- A 100%, Dustin.
Put him and Boyd together.
Let's get Niall's song on the playlist.
Let's get him huge exposure.
- Yeah, thanks, man.
- Done. It's done.
Listen to me on the seventh day a week,
when you go to that place,
turn it into enjoyment, not anxiety.
Meaning when you don't feel it,
then you don't feel it.
I'm telling you enjoy,
and put the down day on a pedestal
of like my body's telling
me I need to rest.
And that's it.
Play video games, watch a movie.
Talk to your bro.
Like convert that beginning, you know,
it's kind of like my back's all fucked up
from growing up in the liquor store
and I've worked on it the last
five years with soft tissue.
So I talk about it a lot.
But last couple of weeks,
cause I've been really going ham
I'm starting really to get
like some things going here.
Like something's clearly
happened where I'm getting,
I'm starting to spasm a
little bit in my back again.
And even though I'm rolling heavily
and I just haven't
completely figured it out.
But it's funny, I equate it to this,
sometimes I can feel my
muscles about to lock
and sometimes I can turn the
right way and it just stops it.
And other times it just, I can't get it.
And it just goes into lock mode.
It's kind of how I think
about the mentality of this.
You know, like when you feel it brewing,
convert it into perspective of
like gratitude of being alive
and lack of judgment on yourself.
And just fucking enjoy the day
and watch your favorite
movie 10 times over,
play video games, or call
your most positive friends.
If you're fighting with
bro at that moment,
call positive friends.
If you're awesome with bro at that moment,
just be thankful for this time.
Be like, bro, let's just
do some different shit.
Let's get into like a Netflix show
or let's fucking play video games.
Like just don't beat yourself up, bro.
This is life.
- At the end of the day like you said,
it's about like loving
what you do and like-
- A hundred.
- I would say like I really
want to be successful and like-
- Period.
Period, stop right
there. Stop right there.
I would argue it would be very hard
for anybody to be more ambitious than me.
I'm in the top tier.
I feel like other people the same.
Like nobody was hungrier.
I'm still, you can't imagine.
I think I'm dirt right now.
I know everything that's going on with me.
And I'm in full dirt mode, garbage,
nothing like haven't even started,
like chip on shoulder.
Like you can't,
if you actually read
the thoughts in my mind,
you'd be like, "what the fuck's
the matter with this dude?"
I'm fucking even like,
like my hunger I'm
fucking starving out here.
However, ambition should
be separate from self-love.
Just, you know what?
Unfortunately people say
ambition, tears them down often.
- For sure.
- You understand?
Your ambition leads to anxiety.
You're like this is why
COVID fucked you up.
You're like, fuck, we had our shit going.
We fly to LA to no, no, no, no.
Take that and be like, no,
we can just make content.
You're so lucky to have each other.
You know how many people are sitting
by themselves right now?
You've got your fucking bros.
You're fucking together.
Fucking make.
- Exactly.
Yeah, It makes you feel-
- Whatever the fucking sign
is behind you in the window,
sell that shit.
Like, like fucking, just go.
Just like I'm telling you,
man, Just go on the offense.
- It's my friend's mirror,
but I'm not telling
- Sell it.
- Sell it, yeah.
- Sell that mirror.
I gotta run. Love you boys.
- Whoa, whoa, one last
- Ask fast.
- 30 seconds.
I'd kill myself if I didn't.
Basically, next time we're
back and forward to LA.
I'd love to get a chance
to get like a real cup of
tea or a beer with you.
And like have like a
little 10 minutes even.
- Get to New York.
You got 10 minutes. It's done
(audio fades)
- Thanks a lot you guys!
- Thank you man.
- Love you guys. Bye bye.
- Peace.
(bad audio)
- Jason.
- Yo ho, Garyvee.
- What's good, bro?
- This is wild man.
- Where are you from?
- I'm out of North Carolina.
- Love it.
- Yeah, Raleigh.
I know you're trying to go
kind of quick right now.
So I just wanted to say, I
hope, hope you're doing well,
hope the family's good.
- Thank you.
- And there was like a little gap
where there weren't any videos coming out
and I was like, Oh man,
I hope everybody's good.
But yeah, like, basically
let me tell you a little bit
about me and my story.
So three years ago I started a company
in my uncle's business, in
the warehouse, in a closet.
It didn't even have lighting.
I'm stealing wifi and printer paper.
And like, you know, it's just
me working 14 hours a day.
Cut to our first full year, 2019.
We're in the black, we did
1.2 million in revenue.
Just like basically the business model is
I sell obsolete electronic parts
to some of the biggest like, you know,
Northrop, Grumman,
Raytheon, Boeing, even NASA.
I've actually even sold some equipment
to your boy over at a Facebook before.
- I love it.
- Yeah, it's cool. It's really cool.
So it's, you know,
and what I've been
thinking lately is like,
this is selling a part, right?
This is selling a physical
piece of equipment,
and I'm trying to, you know, I love it.
I love the business.
I love being an entrepreneur.
I want to go to the next thing.
I want to do something
that's like selling IP,
selling strategy, you know.
And I'm just really curious,
like how did you go from
running the wine business
and selling a physical product
to like, okay, now I
can do the next thing.
- By making content ahead of me doing it.
By sitting down, you know,
I don't know if you've
seen the videos clips
of like 10 years ago where
I was a little chubbier
and like shaved my head
and was making videos during that era.
I just started making content.
And at first people were
like, fuck you wine boy.
Stay in your lane. You
don't know business.
And I'm like, what?
You know, like the feedback
was actually quite negative
when I started making
content around business
because I was in the wine business.
I was in the wine store.
I was a wine guy,
but I just kept making it
because I knew what I was talking about.
And eventually I found my audience,
and my audience found me.
And I just made content on Twitter,
on Ustream on Viddler
on Myspace, on Facebook,
on Socialcam, and Bert, and ARC.
Like all these little startups
at the time, you know,
that Orkut, and hi5
and you know, TagWorld,
all these things that are long forgotten.
But I fucking, I made,
I made, I made, I made.
- So it's interesting you say that-
- Excuse me for one second.
Excuse me for one second. Dustin.
- What's up?
- Can you prep this episode
to end with the announcement
of VaynerGaming?
Cause I see my Twitch family here.
- Okay.
- Maybe the post from Instagram
that I put up yesterday,
maybe you can do that?
- Yep.
- Okay. Thank you.
VaynerGaming.
Go ahead.
- Yeah, it's actually
funny you mentioned that
cause I'm starting to mess a lot,
play with music, DJing and mixing.
And I keep going back
and forth between like,
should I just record every
hour long set or mix?
- Yes.
- Post all of it?
Or should I like get the.
- No.
Jason I know what I'm talking about.
- Yeah, you do. I know that.
- In strengths, the good shit you do
in there is gonna help you.
The flaws, the shit you don't
know, is gonna help you.
- Word.
- Got it?
- Got it man.
- People love the process.
People like the journey.
- Yeah that's so true.
- The Rocky movies are better
in him prepping for the fight
than even the fucking fight.
- Yeah, like it's the imperfection
that makes it interesting.
- A hundred percent.
Everybody I've used, like
I saw somebody who's like
yo why is Garyvee not...
Why is Garyvee's Tea for
Garyvee equipment not up to par?
Like people are complaining
about the sound right now.
Like fuck that, man.
It's the fucking imperfections, like cool.
Go watch some other show
that's got fucking the
best production world.
I got fucking Dustin.
We just fucking sit here.
He presses a button, joke.
We put out great fucking fire,
and we do what we fucking can. The end.
I got fucking back lighting.
I don't give a fuck.
It's the fucking content.
It's the process.
The imperfections are the fucking beauty.
- Got it.
Word. Thank you so much, man.
- You're welcome, buddy.
- That's all I wanted to say.
Yeah, I want to say
I have something for you
that's around the hustling sports cards
and I think it's going
to be extremely helpful.
And if you could follow me on Instagram,
I'll message it to you.
(indistinct)
You're gonna love it. Love it, and-
- I like the hustle because
you know what's cool?
You can just DM it to me
without me following you on the Gram,
but I really want to give you that follow.
So there you go.
- Thank you Gary.
Yo, I appreciate everything you do, man.
Thank you.
- I appreciate you more. We'll talk soon.
Let's keep moving.
- Word.
- Dustin is awesome.
That's the point like Dustin, get in here.
This guy, this guy,
this guy's better than good
lighting and good audio.
People are complaining about
the audio fix it, Dustin.
Let's keep moving.
- Can't, but anyway.
- Is it because of my headphones, Dust,
instead of like plugged in?
- I mean, I think it sounds fine,
but yeah, I think that, I mean,
having these would be better.
- Yeah, I lost them, but I'll find more.
- It's all good.
- See you.
- Oh my gosh, I'm on. Hi Gary!
- Hi. How do you pronounce your name?
- Diana.
- Diana, so pretty.
How are things?
- I am extremely nervous.
So I need to apologize
if you hear some weird
noises in the background,
it's because I'm here with my family.
- I love your family
don't worry about that.
Tell your family to get loud.
Go ahead.
- So, I'll relay a little
bit of a quick backstory
before I asked my question
and it relates a lot
with the person who you
just finished talking to
because it relates to
being at the intersection,
and putting yourself out there.
So I am an artist.
I'm a graphic designer full time.
And I do illustrations
and like my little pins like these.
And I like try to sell them.
So I graduated with an art degree
and I got myself in a lot of debt.
Like a lot, like over a
hundred thousand dollars.
And I didn't like get on it right away
because I was scared
of dealing with money.
My family is also an immigrant family.
We are from Cuba.
I came when I was nine.
So we like worked really hard
and money came always really hard.
And you had to like kind of hoard it
and not spend it, right.
So I was always scared of handling money.
So I didn't tackle that
loan like right away.
So as I got older, I, you know,
I went off to California
and like wanting to do my own thing.
But then the realize about two years in
that I needed to come back
because San Francisco
was way too expensive,
and I needed to do something else.
I moved back with my family
and this is like my room.
And this is where like my
whole life is at pretty much.
Like this is all my stuff.
Like I don't have anything anywhere else.
So my question to you is,
I need to buckle down for
the next year to two years
while I'm here and like
produce art so that I can...
I have a full time job
that I make enough money
that I can kind of pay my bills
and then put it into loan.
But I am trying to produce
more art so that I can sell it,
and I can get a little bit
extra to put into the loan
so I can like close them out.
Biggest thing is
I actually wrote down my
question before I forgot.
It's how do you distance
yourself from your art?
And you know, so like it doesn't feel
like you're putting a
piece of yourself out there
and then feel the rejection
when it's not being,
like people are not liking it,
or commenting it, or buying it.
But you don't want to
take it as a reflection
of who like yourself of course.
Cause I've, I've dealt with a lot of-
- Your account's awesome.
- Thank you.
I keep loosing buyers whenever
I try to be myself on there.
- Yo, what's up with this
bullshit that you don't follow me?
- I follow you on TikTok.
- I love your TikTok stuff.
I will follow you on there too, I promise.
I follow you on TikTok, and Twitter,
and YouTube and everywhere else.
- I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
I follow you.
All right, everybody should follow you.
Because you know what's funny?
Your drawing style is very in my zone.
Like, I like this kind
of characters and stuff.
It's really good.
- Thank you.
- Like really good actually.
- I love creating characters.
So like I'll take a person
and characterize it.
- I'd love for you to do
some stuff for my account
and we'll tag you and give you some....
You should talk to Andy;
I'd love to work with you.
- Definitely, I would love that.
That will be really fun.
- A couple things.
One, I actually don't
think you should detach.
I think you should understand
that you're making the
art that you wanna make.
And sometimes commercially
you'll be successful
and sometimes you don't.
I put out an enormous amount of things
that people don't like
in any shape or form
or give a shit about.
And I find that exciting, not devastating.
I don't take it personal
because I'm not in control
of people's opinions.
I'm in control of what I get to make
because I want to make it.
And sometimes that's going
to be commercially successful
and sometimes it's not.
But I didn't make it to be
commercially successful.
I made it because I wanted to make it.
You need to make it about your process,
not the validation of
people appreciating it.
- Yeah, so I kind of started on TikTok
because I had started before
and I kind of like got off of it
because I wasn't getting
a lot of views and stuff.
And then like, I started listening to you
and I'm like, I need to
get on that like yesterday.
So I started on it.
And I'm posting about one to two a day.
And I always feel really like,
I don't have enough stuff to post
because like creating pins, like these,
like take a long time.
And then I'm creating my illustration
sometimes takes a long time
trying to balance my full
time job with illustrating.
So it's kind of like-
- You do know that you're
one illustration away
from your career changing, right?
- Yeah, I know that, but it
doesn't feel that way to me.
- I don't give a shit
what it feels to you.
I need you to know it's true.
Like here, you're in the cliche spot
that a lot of people
that are watching are in,
which is you're now going
through this whole process
of like, fuck I got into
this debt, I'm back home.
You know, it just makes sense.
The reality is the part
that you don't know
is how young you are.
- Yeah, it doesn't feel that way
because so it goes back to
being with family, right?
So, Hispanic families-
- They're making you feel old.
Yeah. I get it.
Russian families, Chinese families,
Black families, like, you know, I get it.
I get it.
- No, to them I am 30 Years old.
Don't have a significant
other. Don't have kids.
Don't have my life together.
So I hear that all the time.
So trying to shut that off and focus-
- It's hard.
- It's been hard.
Which is why these
things are so important.
You need to shut them out.
You need to be grateful for them.
You can't resent them.
At least they're giving
you a shelter right now
you don't have the cost of home. Right?
You need to be thankful
for what they give you.
And you need to be
empathetic and understanding
why they're stressed.
Your parents, your grandparents,
or whoever's around,
they grew up in a different era
where 30 year old women already
had three fucking children
in the old land, right?
Like, you're a woman of a
new generation, the end.
There's nothing else to say.
Like, I understand where they...
I have a lot of empathy
for where they come from.
That is how they view the world.
I view the world in that at 30,
40 years old I started over.
I spent 12 years of my career
building a big business
for my dad, but I built it for my dad.
I was in a family business.
I didn't get paid a lot of money
because it was the family business.
And I built it for my dad.
And I left at 34 and I had no self,
I had no financial worth.
I was like, had to start over.
So for me,
you can imagine when I
hear 30 and two more years,
I'm like, oh, you're a baby.
And then when I look and actually
see that you're talented,
I'm like, oh shit.
Now all I have to do is get her to believe
that she just needs to put out
as much as she possibly can.
Because it's gonna be one
single piece of content
that's gonna change her world.
Needs one moment.
Look what just happened here.
You got on this show and fucking already,
I'm like interested in working with you.
And I have a huge platform.
It's cause you're great.
Not because, I mean,
there's plenty of people
that have been on the show
that I don't want to work with.
It's cause I think you're
really, really good.
I'm sure you picked up a ton of followers
just right now as well, because let's see.
You've picked up like
300 followers already.
Listen everybody who's here,
please follow right here,
and DM her.
I think some of you
should make logos with her
and pins and like I'd love
for you to make me a design
and we'll make a thousand pins
and then maybe I'll give it away to people
on my text messaging
platform or something.
- Oh yeah. That'll be awesome.
- It's done!
Listen to me. You've got a couple options.
You've got these earbuds
where you just play music
and people that inspire
you all positivity,
all positivity, practical,
positivity, not delusion.
Or you move out and you
move in with friends
so you don't have to hear it.
Those are your two options.
And then you just stay the course.
- Yeah, I'm gonna have to block it off
because right now I need
to focus on those loans.
And I mean, the time that
I've been here already,
I've been able to like close
down three loans, like cash,
like here, take it.
But I still have like two more
that I need to like focus on, right.
And it's that self-worth
that I keep attaching my
self worth to my work.
So when you talk about insecurity
and putting yourself out there
and posting and keep
posting, no matter what
that's where it comes from me.
It's that self worth, I'm attaching it
to what I'm putting out there.
- That's insecurity and ego.
Look, you're not confused
that you're good.
You're too good to not think you're good.
Do you know what I mean?
No matter how insecure or beat up you are,
deep down you know you're good.
So that it's a mix of insecurity and ego
because you know, you're good.
And you need to understand that.
I think I'm the best.
I literally think I'm the best.
Literally, I believe I'm the
best in the world at what I do.
Yet, every day I put out stuff
that nobody gives a shit about.
- It's liberating.
- So just, but how do you-
- Let's start with this.
Dayanna, let's start with this.
What you're doing now, isn't
working for you enough.
You're not happy enough.
So more tuning your parents out.
More putting out content
and getting used to it not doing well.
- Yeah, and that's why I started TikTok.
Cause I wanted, to push myself
to do something out of my comfort zone.
- But you also started doing TikTok
because you believed in me
and it was a new, safe place.
I need you to get comfortable
with negativity and pushback.
Not escape to TikTok to be free.
- Yeah, yeah, you're right.
- TikTok with an outlet
for a lot of people
that got too fancy on Instagram,
that's why it worked for people like,
"Oh, this is easy and fun,
but nobody gives a shit."
Until that becomes the platform
and then the same thing comes over.
We need to fix the well, not the sink.
That was a tactic for
you to escape a place
where judgment was thriving
and insecurity was thriving.
You understand?
It's like it's like training for a fight.
I don't know if you follow boxing or MMA,
but like when you see these people
get punched in the fucking
face or in this ribs
and you're like, or like,
I was watching a fight the other day
and guys slamming on
the guy's fucking toes
and me and my brother and brother-in-law,
are just like laughing.
It'd be like one toe stop would crush us.
That's because we haven't trained
for getting fucking stepped on the toe,
like with fucking all
the other person's might.
However, if I started training right now
for getting stepped on my toes
by another man with all his might,
in two years, I'd be able to handle it.
That's what I needed to do as an artist.
I need you to put out something every day
and get comfortable with losing.
People are uncomfortable with losing.
When you have as much
natural talent as you do,
you probably got good accolades
and positive reinforcement for it.
It became your positive place.
It's the place where you
got positive reinforcement
in your teenage and early years,
it became your safe place.
But now that you're
putting it to the market,
your market's not your teachers,
and your parents, and your friends.
They're going to tell you
go fuck yourself at times.
You need to get comfortable with that.
The game of life
is getting to fall in love
with losing and negativity.
Not with positivity.
- The game of life is predicated
on getting comfortable and enjoy.
I fucking enjoy it.
And I enjoy when they don't like it.
I enjoy when they tell me I can't.
You need to practice.
- Yeah, and the only way to
practice is to put it out there.
- A hundred percent.
It's just opinions.
You also have to know
that when you put out
something that goes viral
or fucking bananas,
you also can't get too high on that.
You can't let the work be the validation.
You need the process of doing
it to be the validation.
You have to figure that out.
- Yeah, that's true.
Like I wanna be able
to focus on the process
and share that as much as I
wanna share the final product.
- So do that.
- But then, yeah.
- But talk, talk.
But?
- So for me,
since my drawings don't turn out perfect.
Like from the very beginning,
it's a process, right?
- Who the fuck's in charge of perfect?
Where's this perfect?
Like besides Curt Hennig,
there is no Mr. Perfect.
There is no Mrs. Perfect.
Like who is this perfect of person?
That's you talking to
yourself about, fuck perfect.
Fuck perfect.
I don't even want to, like,
I don't even say that word
unless I need to address somebody
who's fucking fallen in
love with that fucking word.
That fucking word's a piece of shit.
Perfect is a fucking word
used to make yourself upset.
Fuck that word.
- I mean, I use it as
procrastination as well.
Like I end up not doing it
because I want it perfect.
- Perfect is a veil for not doing.
- That's so true.
I'm like my heart is like beating so fast
because I honestly think that
this was put in front of me
to talk to you today like as a sign,
because I honestly just
started following you
like a few weeks ago.
And I've been listening
to your stuff like,
back and forth while I work.
- There are so many people,
there are thousands of
thousand people here
who've been watching for seven years,
have been dying to get on this show,
and you're out here like,
"Yo, I met you yesterday; here I am."
I love it.
- I texted you. I texted
your number yesterday.
And I was like,
I don't know if this is
gonna go through or not.
But like I still asked my
question and then saying reply.
And I was like, holy shit.
Like what is going on?
This is like a sign from the universe.
And I cannot be more
thankful for the opportunity
to share it with you.
And I'm gonna rewatch this clip like-
- Every day. Exactly.
When you walk into your home,
when you leave your home,
you put in those ear pods
and you listened to this.
Literally, literally, literally
and that's escaping like Tiktok.
At some point you sit down
with your parents and say,
I am so thankful that I've
parents that love me so much.
And don't think I have my life together.
And I understand you
and the way you grew up,
but I promise you, I do.
And I have so much more time
to make it perfect for me.
And I hope you enjoy the way
I decide to live my life.
And I understand immigrant parents,
you're not talking to somebody
who doesn't understand.
- Yeah, they want you to follow
like a straight line of what life is.
- They want you to live the
life that they want you to live.
The problem is that's not
in your best interest.
- Yeah. It's not, and I'm not that way.
I don't think that way either.
That's what causes the tension
between us and the fights
and the, you know.
- You need to become more selfless
when you talk to your parents.
Instead of worrying
about defending yourself,
you need to actually reverse it.
You need to flip it on them and say,
I love you so much for
caring about me so much.
You gotta flip it on them.
You gotta Eminem them, you know,
like Eminem and 8 Mile when he like,
distanced himself and
then the other guy's like,
"What the fuck?"
You need to basically do that
same thing with your parents.
I love you, thank you, thank you.
And then after a while you
do that great transition
that he does to clearance.
You say, mom, I love you.
Mom, I love you. Mom, I love you.
And then you say, you know, Mom,
I do know something about you.
I know that you resent dad for this.
And I know that you're mad
that you started having kids this early.
And I know that you're pissed
that you never got to follow your dream.
When you flip that shit on parents.
I love you. I love you.
I love you. Instead of fuck you.
This is my life. You don't know.
Instead of that, I love you.
I love you. I love you.
Thank you for caring about me.
Thank you for giving me life.
Thank you for the shelter.
Thank you for the support.
Now that's a different way
of addressing the issue.
And then maybe after a
month or two of that,
if you go into, you know, Mom,
I do know something about you
and you flip the judgment,
then shit gets really interesting.
- Yeah, I need to do that more.
I tend to be very defensive
on everything that they say
about me for everything.
- Correct, flip it, flip it.
Flip it.
Don't be defensive. Be grateful.
- And I know they mean well.
- You just beat me to it.
You know how many people
are watch right now
who have parents that don't give a fuck?
- Yeah,
I know.
- So be thankful.
Every time they come at you with like,
"What are you doing?
30 years old, your cousin
Maria's fucking married."
You know, all that shit.
You just say, thank you for
caring about me so much,
but I got this, thank you.
I appreciate you caring.
It means the world to me that
I have parents that care.
And then after you build
a little bit of that,
you go, by the way.
And that is where it gets interesting.
Which is like, I appreciate
your judgment of me,
now let me give you a
little bit about you.
- Yeah. And I've, you know,
it's not to try to
change them or anything.
It's more of like trying
to have them understand
where I'm coming from
and how thankful I am for everything
that they're doing for me,
but also understand me,
which to this day they haven't
quite figured me out yet.
- Yeah, it's maybe also
because of the way you
communicate yourself to them.
- Yeah, I'm super defensive,
like super defensive.
- Never works.
All right, good luck.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome so much.
Good show.
Good show, Dust.
- Very good.
- Long ones.
Important ones.
I like it.
Something I wanted to talk about.
You're gonna end with
VaynerGaming big announcement.
- Small announcement.
Tomorrow, Seth is going to be doing this
instead of me.
- Oh snap action tomorrow.
That's walking into a buzzsaw
we're gonna transition to somebody else.
People get real testy.
Well, okay, cool.
You gonna be hanging
with him or he's ready.
- I'll be like, I'll still be here.
It's just a rotating type of thing.
- No, no, we need to build that up.
All right, love everybody.
Hope everybody has a great day.
(212) 931-5731.
If you want to get your
question on the show.
If want to get your question,
hit me up with a question.
Somebody asked, Josh Allen or Darnold.
It's not even close.
Darnold's gonna be 10 times
better pro than Josh Allen.
Oh, you Buffalo fans are confused as fuck.
Confused as fuck by the
soft schedule last year.
You weren't paying attention
to how he plays out.
Awesome, love you.
See you, bye.